anch'io ho un sogno come martin luther
king
anch'io ho un sogno che purtroppo forse
non realizzerò mai che è quello di
volare nello spazio extra terrestre
volare al di fuori della nostra
atmosfera sopra le nubi là dove non ci
sono le luci della nostra città è un
sogno come vi dicevo che ha affascinato
da sempre filosofi poeti musicisti qui
vedete un film del 1900 in cui george
méliès si immagina di spedire verso la
luna 3 ardimentosi astronauti vedete che
aveva anche delle belle veline che con
grande maestria caricano il cannone e lo
indirizzano il proiettile verso la luna
da allora sono passati tanti anni siamo
invasi da tanti i film di fantascienza
più o meno belli ma chi insomma
testimoniano che questo sogno continua
è un sogno che può essere realizzato
oggi da pochi fortunati a bordo della
stazione spaziale ma che diventa sempre
più concreto ci sono già compagni e
agenzie che programmano voli suborbitali
hanno già venduto migliaia di biglietti
e quindi io penso che tra pochi anni ci
sarà qualcuno di noi che potrà andare a
vedere la bellissima italia dallo spazio
non potrà addirittura entrare
letteralmente entrare in un aurora
boreale e poi più avanti verso la luna e
non è un problema facile non ci sono
diciamo solo attrattive ci sono anche
dei pericoli di cui dobbiamo essere ben
coscienti per affrontarli e per
superarla
ad esempio tra questi pericoli c'è il
sole
lo stesso sole che produce le bellissime
aurore boreali e mette anche però delle
vere e proprie tempeste
elettromagnetiche sono particelle
cariche molto energetiche che rischiano
di danneggiare le nostre attrezzature
danneggiare il nostro corpo e che
dobbiamo in qualche modo cercare di
vincere con adatti protezioni sulla
navicella e sulle nostre tute molto al
sole ci sono gli stessi razzi rasi che
vengono lanciati ormai a un ritmo
impressionante è che dissipano nella
nostra atmosfera
un'enorme quantità di gas che non
c'erano all'inizio ma non solo gas
rilasciano anche tanti detriti e vedete
che il loro numero è pure sivamente
aumentato in questi decenni
rappresentano un pericolo per le orbite
più basse ma rappresentano un pericolo
anche per le orbite più alte quelle ad
esempio da cui trasmettono i nostri
satelliti di telecomunicazioni qualche
volta un satellite esplode provocando
altri detriti
magari causando anche dei problemi di
assicurazione e regali di non facile
soluzione detriti dunque che noi
dobbiamo in qualche modo cercare di
andare a raccogliere un'attività di veri
e propri spazzini spaziali per così dire
vedete qua una soluzione un ragnetto che
con la sua bellissima puntura rende noto
un satellite che si era perduto
oppure allo stile di un'eresia ario
romano di un gladiatore che cattura con
la sua rete satellite e l'europa è
all'avanguardia in questo settore c'è
tutto un progetto che si chiama di
spazio pulito di spazio verde
un progetto che complessivamente
comprende molti tecnici molti scienziati
ma anche piccole aziende anche del nord
sul territorio e che cerca di rendere
sempre più sicuro e sempre più attraente
andare nello spazio andare nello spazio
dall'orbita vicina alla terra un giorno
ci trasferiremo sulla luna per fare i
turisti telefonare a casa ma anche per
il provvedimento xi scalare le montagne
ce ne sono anche altri il doppio di
quelle terrestri quindi ci vogliono dei
buoni alpinisti andare su quei picchi
verso i poli della luna dove non
tramonta mai il sole picchi detti della
luce eterna
oppure penetrare in un crepaccio lunare
dove una cometa magari un miliardo di
anni fa ha dissipato una grande quantità
di ghiaccio ma possiamo fare anche di
più possiamo pensare di andare dalla
faccia visibile della luna sapere
vediamo solo una faccia della luna ma
l'altra si è completamente invisibile e
il fascino dell'ignoto poter andare dove
nessun altro uomo ha mai messo piede e
possiamo usare la duna anche per
sfruttare i suoi giacimenti minerari
terre rare che sulla terra ormai si
diventano appunto sempre più rare altre
sostanze
e qui naturalmente si pongono anche
tanti problemi legali di chi è quel
particolare campo sulla luna chi mi dà
il permesso di scavare su un meteorite
mi danneggia l'apparecchiatura chimera
ripaga possiamo anche pensare di più qui
vedete un aeroporto lunare lascia trici
da una gentile civiltà extraterrestre da
cui partire verso marte e si preparano a
queste esplorazioni dei ragazzi qua
vicini a noi a innsbruck e agras che
forti della loro esperienza sulle alpi
hanno disegnato delle tute
particolarmente importanti per scendere
ad esempio nella valle marineris che
granché
di marte oppure andare nelle grotte di
ghiaccio verso i poli di marte dove ci
sarà tanta informazione sul passato del
nostro sistema solare ma anche in italia
abbiamo tante belle attività che mi
piace ricordare un gruppo di roma ha
appena vinto una grande gara
internazionale sono stati invitati dalla
nasa al lancio di un razzo verso marte
perché avevano concepito disegnato una
bellissima serva marziana in cui fare
crescere vegetali ma anche fiori con cui
ingentilire un terreno che altrimenti è
tanto arido e noi qui a padova cosa
abbiamo
abbiamo innanzitutto la grandissima
tradizione lasciataci da galileo galilei
vi leggo solo quello che scrisse nel
io non ho dubbi diceva che se potessi
vedere la terra da lontano se dallo
spazio vedrei le terre e chiare e i mari
scuri e queste come vediamo alla terra
da marte
notate la aderenza la straordinaria
aderenza di quello che si immaginava
galileo con quello che vediamo oggi è
quindi oggi noi possiamo vedere quello
che galileo poteva solo immaginare e
possiamo anche renderci conto di come
sia fragile questo ambiente terrestre di
come sia importante renderlo sempre più
adatto ai bisogni dell'uomo sempre più
verde come ho detto nel titolo ea padova
stiamo facendo molto
l'eccellenza di galileo sia trasferita
nei nostri laboratori si fa tanta
ricerca ma anche a livello più basso
oppure universitario che vedete un
gruppo di ragazzi del fermi che da due
anni vincono una gara internazionale per
come sono bravi a far navigare degli
oggetti nello spazio ma non ci sono solo
questi ragazzi ad esempio mi chiedo ma
la grande tradizione a cui si è
accennato prima enogastronomica padovana
la grande tradizione di accoglienza di
ospitalità si deve trasferire nello
spazio io immagino uno che inventi una
bottiglia di prosecco che si può aprire
anche in assenza di gravità senza
disperdere tutto il liquido
nell'astronave one d'albergo dunare
abbiamo anche dei ragazzi che
volontariamente si occupano di istruire
le scolaresche riportano a vedere il
cielo ad asiago è nato né tario qua di
padova
quindi una serie di attività che
coinvolgono tantissimi di voi e di noi
che quindi merita di essere portata
avanti e quando la notte scende sul
deserto di atacama in cile e appaiono in
cielo
tante belle stelle e le due nubi di
magellano
e come se il grande esploratore
portoghese mi dicesse raccogliete la mia
bandiera proseguite l'esplorazione e
intanto che che faccio questa mia lunga
veglia notturna da da astronomo mi
vengono in mente le parole di pirandello
pirandello che dice fantasie
no signori realtà realtà grazie